[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله وكل عيد
وانتم بخير معكم ال سي ابي عاصي وفي الوقت
الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى
هذه الصور المباشره تردنا من مكه المكرمه
حيث يواصل الحجيج اداء مناسك الحج في مشعر
منى
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر في مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
ارتفاع حده المعارك في الجبهات الشرقيه في
اوكرانيا القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل
محاولاتها لاستعاده ضخمه بالتقدم من
الشمال والجنوب
وتتهم القوات الروسيه بقصف اهداف مدنيه في
كراماتورس
لن تتخلى عن اي من اهدافها العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ووزير الدفاع الامريكي يقول ان
حربكيه من اجل سيادتها بلغت لحظه مهمه
مستقبل فاغنر اسئله تلد اخرى قائد
بالمجموعه يقول انها باتت تحتفظ في
بيلاروسيا بقدرات قتاليه كبيره وانها على
مقربه من كييف الرئيس البولندي يصف وجودها
في بيلاروسيا بالتهديد لبلاده الكريم لن
يتجه الى السيطره على كامل عمليات
المجموعه في سوريا وافريقيا وبايدن يقول
ان من الصعب معرفه ما اذا كانت تحركات
الاخيره اضعفت نفوذ بوتين
اشتباكات السودان المستمره تقطع الطريق
امامه الدات العيد البرهان يبدي قبولا
للتعامل مع اي مبادره تركيه بعد اتصال
هاتفي باردوغان الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول
انها تواصل العمل على وقف الصراع وسفير
النرويجي بالخرطوم يطالب في مقابله مع
الجزيره لمزيد من الضغط الاقليمي والدولي
لوقف اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
مقتل شاب على يد شرطي في فرنسا يثير
احتجاجات بلغت ضواحي باريس وزاره الداخليه
تدفع بنحو الفيرج والامن اضافي بعد
اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين والشرطه واحراق
مقرات امنيه وبعد اتهامات للامن بالتستر
على حقيقه العمليه قرار بتمديد اعتقال
الشرطي والتحقيق معه بتهمه القتل العمد
ومكروه يدعو للهدوء ويقول ان عمليه القتل
غير مبرره
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الاضطرابات التي تعيشها
فرنسا على خلفيه مقتل شاب على يد شرطي في
باريس وزير الداخليه اعلن اصابه اربعه
وعشرين شرطيا واعتقال واحدا 31 شخصا خلال
اعمال عنف شهدتها ضواحي باريس مشيرا الى
الدفع بمزيد من التعزيزات خشيه اتساع رقعه
الاحتجاجات بينما وجه الادعاء العام تهمه
القتل العمد للشرطي ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
في اي مسار تذهب الاحتجاجات في فرنسا بعد
مقتل شاب على يد شرطي بشكل متعمد بحسب
تهمه الادعاء العام 71% توقعوا اتساع رقعه
الاحتجاجات وتصاعدها بينما راى 29% انه
بالامكان احتواء الازمه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
اذا قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها تقدمت
نحو مدينه باخموت وانا اسقطت ست مسيرات من
نوع شاهد ايرانيه الصنع فوق دينيبرو فيما
اشاره الى ان القوات الروسيه تواصل قصف
المناطق بما في ذلك اهداف مدنيه في
كراماتورز حديث الجانب الاوكراني يتزامن
مع اخر تاكيد روسي بشان مستقبل الحرب حيث
قال وزير الخارجيه
انما وصفها بالعمليه العسكريه مستمره وان
موسكو لن تتخلى عن اهدافها رغم احداث
فاجنر بدوره قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ان معركه اوكرانيا من اجل سيادتها تمر
بلحظه حاسمه
مشتعله تبقى عده محاور بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني لا سيما عند نقاط التماس
الاساسيه التطور الابرز في الجبهه يدور
عند ضفاف نهر النيبر
فيسك قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت
سته مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع
وشهدت مدينه زابوشيا التي تقع تحت السيطره
اوكرانيا عده انفجارات في الساعات الماضيه
في وقت ما زالت محطه
تحت السيطره الروسيه وفي مناطق قريبه من
مدينه باخموت تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تشتبك بشكل مباشر مع الجيش الروسي في عده
نقاط وتتحدث عن تحقيق بعض التقدم الميداني
لا سيما عند سد كورديوموفوسكوي المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه نفت تحقيق اوكرانيا
اي تقدم وقالت ان الغرب لم يقم استنتاجات
على خلفيه فشل هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه
المضاد كراماتورسك التي تعتبر خط الهجوم
الاوكراني باتجاه تعرضت لقصف مكثف او قاع
قتلى وجرحى وصفته كييف بهجوم ارهابي
القوات الروسيه ردت على الاتهامات بنفس
استهداف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه واكدت ان
اهدافها تقتصر على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه
ومن الامور اللافته ميدانيا استمرار تعرض
مدينه دانيات الاوكرانيه فرغم مرور قرابه
تسع سنوات على اعلان انفصاليين موالين
لروسيا السيطره عليها لا تزال المدينه غير
امنه بالكامل
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من جناب الكسند رئيس وتحرير
المجله العسكريه السويسريه مرحبا بك سيد
اليكسون ما الذي يحصل في مدن الشرق نشاهد
دراوه كبيره في القتال الروسي ايضا ضراوه
في الهجمات الاوكرانيه مع تاكيد اوكراني
من جانب وزير الدفاع ان الهجوم المضاد لم
يبدا بعد
في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن معركه ضاريه في
الاسابيع الماضيه بدات العمليات
الاستطلاعيه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
الاوكرانيه
جنوبولوجيا واستمرت في منطقه خرسون وكان
هناك عدد من العمليات الاوكرانيه في الشرق
حتى الان معظم هذه العمليات الاستطلاعيه
كان لديها نجاحات محدوده وحوالي خمسه عشر
الى عشرين بالمئه من القوات الاوكرانيه
انخرطت بعمليات الاستطلاع هذه طيب ماذا عن
باخموت يبدو انها تعود الى دائره القتال
الى اي مدى هناك رهان اوكراني على استعاده
باخموت بشكل كامل بعد التمرد الذي او
نتائج التمرد التمرد
فاغنر في داخل روسيا
الوضع في بخموت يمكن ان نفهمه من خلال
القول بان وحده المظليين الروسيه وقوات
فاجنر
اخرجت من بخموت بعد او خرجت بعد نجاحها في
السيطره على المدينه والقوات الروسيه
الاخوات النخبه استبدلت بجنود الليل
يتمتعون بنفس مستوى الخبره وما رايناه في
الاسبوع او الاسبوعين الماضيين هو عمليات
اوكرانيا في الشمال
والجنوب وتقدمت
بمساحه قطرها 15 كيلومتر الى عشرين كيلو
متر وبالتالي هناك قلق كبير في الجانب
الروسي بانه يتعين على القوات الروسيه ان
تقاتل من جديد في بخموت ولكن هنا اود ان
اقول ان روسيا خسرت عشره بالمئه من قواتها
في هذه العمليه في تلك المنطقه كانت نتيجه
لمحاوله الانقلاب او التمرد المسلح الذي
قامت به قوات فاجنر وبالتالي هذه القوات
لا يمكن ان تستخدم الان والنقطه الثانيه
هي ان الاوكرانيين الذين يتقدمون ايضا
قالوا ان لديهم خسائر كبيره
يقول وزير الدفاع ان الحرب او حرب كياز من
اجل استعاده سيادتها بلغت لحظه مهمه
نحن امام ماذا
ان الحرب هي في مرحله مهمه ومفصليه لانه
بالنظر الى المخزون المتاح اليوم هناك
امكانيه اجراء هجوم حاسم وكبير هذه
العمليه الحاسمه على الارجح سوف تجري في
مكان ما في الجنوب وهذا ما يتوقعه جميع
الاطراف ولكننا لم نشاهد بعد هذه العمليه
واسعه النطاق في المقابل روسيا على لساني
تقول انها لن تتخلى عن اي من اهداف من
اهدافها العسكريه في اوكرانيا ماذا ستكون
الترجمه العمليه لهذا الكلام باعتقادك في
الميدان
الترجمه
العمليه منذ شهر ديسمبر كانت ان القوات
الروسيه انتقلت من عمليه هجوميه حاولت من
خلالها ان تستولي على اكبر قدر ممكن من
الاراضي الى عمليه دفاعيه وامضت القوات
الروسيه اسابيع واشهر في تعزيز مواقعها
الدفاعيه لكي تتاكد من قدرتها على صد
الهجوم المضاد المحتمل وهذا ما نراه في
الجانب الروسي تعزيز للمواقع وكنتيجه لذلك
لدى القوات الاوكرانيه خيار وحيد الا وهو
الهجوم من اجل اعاده السيطره على الاراضي
التي فقدتها القوات الاوكرانيه شكرا لك من
جناف الكسند رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه
[موسيقى]
اسئله كثيره تطرح بشان مصير مجموعه فاجنر
فبعد انتقال مالكها الى بيلاروسيا قال
قائد عسكري فيها ان وجود المجموعه في
بيلاروسيا على مسافه نحو 100 كيلومتر من
كياف يثير قلق الناتو وبولندا تحذير ضمني
اقره الرئيس البولندي بتحذيره من ان
التموضع المحتمل لفاجنر خطر ينبغي
الالتفات اليه الحديث عن المجموعه لم يعد
يقتصر على حدود المعركه في اوكرانيا حيث
نقلت صحيفه عن مصادر بان الكرملين يحاول
السيطره على كامل اعمال المجموعه وان
مقاتلي فاجنر في سوريا امتثلوا للاوامر
وانضموا لقاعده حميم تطورات تاتي مع تعليق
امريكي من الرئيس جو بايدن الذي قال انه
من الصعب معرفه واذا كانت الاحداث الاخيره
قد اضعفت بوتين
مسلسل من حلقات محدوده ام بمواسم متعدده
وحبكه دراميه متقلبه غموض يزيد ولا ينقص
لما جرى في روسيا السبت الماضي اهو تمرد
كما يسميه الكرملين اما مسرحيه كما يصفها
خصوم بوتين ام صراع اجنحه داخل البيت
الروسي ام فوضى نجحت موسكو في احتوائها
قبل فوات الاوان ام ماذا بالضبط من سحاب
قواته من مخطط الزحف الى موسكو الذي لم
يعمر سوى ساعات لم تنتهي القصه ولم تقلب
صفحه الخصومه قائد مجموعه في ضيافه الرئيس
البيلاروسي لوكاشينكو منذ صباح الثلاثاء
الرئيس الذي تولى الوساطه تتحدث ربما اكثر
من اللازم عن تفاصيل الاتصالات التي
اجراها مع بوتين وبريكوجين قال لوكاشينكو
ان بوتين كان يريد تصفيه الطباخه السابق
ولكنه دعاه الى عدم القيام بذلك
ولكن ماذا ينتظر بريكوشين ورفاقه بعد الان
هل الاقامه في بيلاروسيا ستكون طويله ام
قصيره كان الرئيس بوتين وضمن اتفاقه مع
نظيره البيلاروسي لاحمد دينار الفتنه عطل
قرار الملاحق القانونيه وخير مقاتلي
المجموعه العسكريه بين العوده الى منازلهم
او الانخراط في الجيش النظامي او التوجه
الى الجاره بلاروسيا بالرغم من المشهد
القاتم والعلاقه المتشابكه بين الكرملين
وفاكنر موسكو غير مستعده لتسليم ولا غيره
لاي دوله اخرى من اجل محاكمته
[موسيقى]
في الجانب القانوني المتعلق بالتسليم
استطيع القول ان اي مواطن روسي لا يخضع
للتسليم لاي دوله اخرى وله الحق في اي
يعول على مساعده روسيا لحمايته من
المحاولات غير القانونيه لتحميله
المسؤوليه الجنائيه في الخارج
اشارت الخارجيه الروسيه ايضا الى ان
الزعماء الافارقه هم اصحاب قرار مواصله
العمل من عدمه مع مجموعه قبل يومين من هذا
الكلام كان وزير الخارجيه
اكد استمرار عمل المجموعه في افريقيا
الوسطى ومالي صخر الكريم من محتوى تقرير
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وجاء في التقرير
استنادا الى مصدر في المخابرات الامريكيه
ان الجنرال
نائبه قائد العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
كان على علم بالتمرد قبل وقوعه علقت قائلا
انه ستكون هناك الكثير من التكهنات
والشائعات وما الى ذلك بشان هذه الاحداث
مضيفا ان ما ورد في التقرير مجرد نموذج
بالنسبه لواشنطن في السبت ماده قابله
للاستغلال الى ابعد الحدود وان حاول
الرئيس جو بايدن التاكيد اعتبار مجره شان
داخليا لا يخفي شمتته من عدوه اللدود في
موسكو
من الواضح ان بوتين يخسر الحرب في
اوكرانيا ويخسر حرب الداخل واصبح منبوذا
نوعا ما في جميع انحاء العالم
بعد بيلاروسيا اين ستذهب فاجنر ورئيسها هل
ستحل لتعود بعلامه تجاريه جديده ورئيس
اكثر ولاء للمؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه واقل
تهورا هل ستبقى كما هي ولكن تحت اي بند
ستكون علاقتها مع الكريم بعد الان
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من ولايه
المدير السابق لمكتب روسيا في البنتاجون
ومعنى من موسكو فلاديمير ييرانوسيان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكم
سنبدا معك سيد فلاديمير بعد تمرد بريغوجين
ومال اليه وضعه الان ما هو اطار عمل فاجنر
يجب ان نفهم ان القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه السيد فاديمير بوتين سمى كل شيء
على اصله وقال ان هذا
تمرد مسلح وبعد هذا في البث المباشر قال
ووضح ان مجموعه فاقنر كانت
قد عاشت على الانفاق الحكومي وقال ان
حوالي
8 مليار روبل كانت تقدم لهذه المجموعه
وهذا يعني ان دون التمويل الحكومي
بالاموال والمعدات ما كانت مجموعه لتكون
موجوده في اوكرانيا ولما استطاعت ان تقوم
بالمهمات العامه التي كانت تقف امام
القوات المسلحه لو سمحت لنستفيد من الوقت
يعني دعنا من الماضي اصبحت واضحه كل هذه
الامور وتحدث بها كما ذكرت الرئيس الروسي
ولكن نحن نتحدث الان في المستقبل يعني
مستقبلا كيف سيكون اطار عمل هذه المجموعه
المسلحه
في هذه اللحظات السيد
موجود في روسيا في بيروسيا تحت رقابه كما
قالها تحت رقابه صديقه الرئيس البيروسي
الذي اظهر نفسه كوصيد فعال
ولذلك تحت سيطره الكوشنكا هذه المجموعه او
جزء منها دعونا نقول دون اي معدات
ثقيله سوف تتواجد في بروسيا وعلى اغلب
الظن لوكاشينك سوف يستخدم القيادات الاكثر
فعاليه
الذين كانوا في
الاعمال الاوكرانيه حتى يستخدم في القوات
الخاصه البيروسيه وسوف تكون لدى حوالي 7
جندي اعتقد انهم سوف
اعتقد انهم سوف يدربون القوات البيروسيه
على المعارك في المدن لان قوات فاجنر ذات
خبره في هذا المجال وكيف يقوم
بالتعامل وضحت الفكره دعنا نذهب الى السيد
مات اوضح لنا السيد فلاديمير الشكل الذي
ستعمل وفقه قوات فاجنر الان في بيلاروسيا
ويقول انها ستكون دون اي معدات ثقيله
بالتالي هل هذه المخاوف التي تعبر عنها
بولندا وليتوانيا مبرره
ان اي من دول حلف شمال الاطلسي ولا بولندا
ولا ليتوانيا ولا اي دوله اخرى لديها اي
داعي للقلق بشان اعضاء مجموعه
دخلوا الى بيلاروسيا كما ذكرتم الاسلحه
الثقيله سوف تصادرها الحكومه الروسيه وسوف
توزعها على القوات الروسيه المنظمه منظمه
سوف تفكك على الارجح اجزاء منها سوف تفكك
ولكن الالاف الذين اصطفوا الى جانب
بريجوجن وانتهى بهم المطاف في بيلاروسيا
لا اعتقد انه سوف يسمح اليهم بان يؤثروا
من خلال نظام الاستقرار في بيلاروسيا على
اي اساس اذا باعتقادك سيدمك يعبر
المسؤولون في ليتوانيا وبولندا عن المخاوف
وينشدون حمايه من الناتو اذا
هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه لا اعرف بالضبط ما
يعرفونه بشان التهديدات المرتبطه بمجموعه
ولكن على
الارجح هذا جزء من التصريحات العامه في
هذين البلدين بيلاروسيا وروسيا هما بلدان
يزعزعان الاستقرار في المنطقه وتندرج هذه
التصريحات في هذا السياق التاكد من حمايه
الجناح الشرقي لحلف شمال الاطلسي ومنع
توسع انعدام الاستقرار
يقول السيد ورايتك توافقه الى حد ما بانه
سيجري تفكيك فاجنر ولكن ماذا عن مصير
اعمال هذه مجموعه عسكريه منتشره في
افريقيا
منتشره موجوده في سوريا ماذا سيحصل بكل
هذه المهمات التي كانت تتولاها نيابه عن
روسيا
الواقع مجموعه فاقنر هي مجموعه من
المرتزقه المستاجرين عندما تدفع لهم
يعملون لذلك
التمويل الذي سوف يقف في منطقه او في احد
مسارح العمليات لا يعني عدم توقيع
العقود مع وزاره الدفاع من قبل مجموعات
فاقنر الاخرى في المناطق الاخرى من الكوكب
هذا يعني ان المجموعات الاخرى من قوات
فاغنر في الدول الاخرى سوف توقع عقود مع
وزاره الدفاع وسوف تحصل على التمويل
الضروري كاي اعضاء من وزاره الدفاع وسوف
يعمل على اساس الاتفاق مع الدوله ذات
السياده التي تقوم بدعوه المتخصصين
العسكريين من قبلنا
للدفاع عن سيادتها بالنسبه لابتسامه اثناء
حديث الضيف الذي تحدث عن مخاوف بولندا
بولندا دائما تتخاوف بهدف واحد انت طالب
باموال كبيره من الاتحاد الاوروبي
والاسلحه دون اي موضوع من الزعماء
الامريكي ابقى معك فيما يتعلق بمستقبل
فاجنر انت قلت سيتم ان تقول سيد فلاديمير
سيتم الدفع لهم من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اذا يستمرون في المهام حيث يطلب منهم ولكن
الان هناك شيء مهم حصل سابقا لم تكن روسيا
تعترف بانها بان قوات فاجنر مموله منها
وتتبع لها وبالتالي كانت تقوم بعمليات
نيابه عن روسيا بشكل سري الان مع هذا
الاعتراف من جانب بوتين بانها مموله ويتم
تمويلها وهي تابعه بالكامل لروسيا كيف
سيتبدل ستتبدل مهامها كيف سيؤثر ذلك على
مهامها
هذا ليس تماما كما تحدثت عنه لانه كلامك
قد يكون صحيح جزئيا ولكن في مسرح اعمال
واحد في ارثار
في اي في لوغانست ولكن بالنسبه لدعوه
الشركه العسكريه
الخاصه الى افريقيا الوسطى هناك كانت
الاحداث والمهام تنفذ على اساس عقود خاصه
بين شركات عسكريه والان بعد
بعدما قام العسكريين السابقين المتواجدين
في قوات اتفقنار الان يتم اجبارهم بتوقيع
او يطلب منهم توقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع
وهناك اسم متخصصين ممكن ان نحتاج لاعمالهم
وقد يتم استخدامهم للاستمرار في
التي تتناسب مع مصلحه الوطن فانهم ابطال
وجنود
سيد مادمك كيف سيؤثر هذا الاعتراف من جانب
من جانب روسيا بان هي من تقف وراء فاجنر
هي من تمول فاجنر على مستقبل اعمال هذه
الشركه في مناطق مختلفه تقوم باعمال فيها
نعم اعتقد ان فلاديمير بوتين صرح بشكل
علني بما كان الجميع يعرفه في السابق
الحكومه الروسيه تمول فاغنر بالنسبه الى
قطعه تمويل اعتقد ان بعض اعضاء فاجنر سوف
ينخرطون في عمليه جديده باداره جديده وسوف
يستمرون باداء مهامهم في افريقيا في منطقه
شرق الاوسط لربما سوف يكون المقر الرئيسي
بالنسبه اليهم بيلاروسيا
وهنادينا عدد من الجنود السابقين الجنود
السابقين الذين يمكنهم ان يعملوا في
بيلاروسيا
والحكومه الروسيه ترحب بهم وبعملهم في
افريقيا وفي منطقه الشرق الاوسط بنيابه عن
روسيا واتوقع ان تؤمن الحكومه الروسيه في
المستقبل التمويل لهذه العمليات ولكن يجب
ان اتذكر ان
في عدد كبير منها مموله ذاتيا في افريقيا
من الحكومات الافريقيه وبالتالي باستطاعه
شركه ان تجد موارد اضافيه شكرا لك مع
المدير السابق لمكتب روسيا في
الولايات المتحده وشكرا فلاديمير
ييرانوسيان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيفنا من موسكو من موسكو
[موسيقى]
قال مراسل الجزيره ان طائرات حربيه تابعه
للجيش السوداني شنت غارات جويه على مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع في محيط احياء
المنصوره والمهندسين والافتحاب جنوبيه ام
درمان بالعاصمه السودانيه اضاف مراسلنا ان
اعمده الدخان تصاعدت من المناطق التي شهدت
القصف كما سمع دوي في جارات بالتزامن مع
اصوات مضادات جويه
ذلك مع اطلاق نار متقطع من اسلحه ثقيله
جنوبيه ام درمان احدى مدن العاصمه
السودانيه الثلاث ومع اعلان رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان وقفا لاطلاق
النار من جانب واحد في اول ايام عيد
الاضحى وقالت مصادر محليه ان المواقع
المستهدفه بالغارات هي تجمعات جديده لم
تكن موجوده قبل الهده التي اعلن عنها طرفا
القتال كل على حده دون اتفاق بينهما
بمناسبه عيد الاضحى
وتلقى رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان اتصالا هاتفيا من الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي اكد استعداد انقره
لاستمرار تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه واكد
البرهان استعداد السودان لقبول اي مبادره
تركيه لايقاف الحرب واحلال السلام بدورها
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه انها تواصل العمل
على وقف الصراع
سودان
مناظر ومبادره الحل والازمه
تطفو من الخرطوم اخبار مبادره تركيه في
اتصال هاتفي من الرئيس التركي برئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي بدا
مرحبا بها لم تتحدد لا ملامحها ولا افاقها
في انقره حيث اقتصر بيان الرئاسه التركيه
على الكلام عن استمرار تقديم الخدمات
للسودانيين قبل ذلك تدخلت اطراف عده امميه
وافريقيه لكنها اخفقت لسبب او لاخر فمنبر
بحجم الامم المتحده بدا عاجزا عن احداث
اختراق في الازمه منذ نشوبها وهي التي
انشات بعثه متكامله لمساعده السودان عام
2020 عينت على راسها الالماني الذي سرعان
ما توترت علاقته بالخرطوم التي طلبت
باستبداله بسبب ادائه الذي منح انطباعا
سلبيا عن حياديه الامم المتحده واحترامها
لسياده الدول كما تقول الحل الافريقي
بدوره قطع شوطا على الاقل على المنابر وفي
التصريحات والمبادرات نهايه في العاصمه
الاثيوبيه اديس ابابا اجتماع لمجلس السلم
والامن الافريقي على مستوى رؤساء الدول
الاعضاء في المجلس واكد عناصر سته وردت في
خريطه الطريق ابرزها انشاء اليه تنسيق
لجهود الجهات الاقليميه والعالميه والوقف
الفوري والدائم والشامل للاعمال العدائيه
وان تكون هناك عمليه السلام واحده وشامله
وموحده من اجل السودان وتحت رعايه مشتركه
من الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه الدول العربيه
والامم المتحده
رفضت الخرطوم على لسان نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده ملك عقار مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي
وذلك بسبب تعليق عضويه السودان
وبموازاتها كانت لجنه وساطه تضم كينيا
وجنوب السودان وجيبوتي واثيوبيا مكلفه من
الايجاد تبحث مبادره جديده اقرتها قمه
رؤساء الدول والحكومات لمنظمه
وتضمنت جعل الخرطوم منطقه منزوعه السلاح
من طرفي النزاع الى ان تحل محلها قوه حفظ
سلام افريقيه واطلاق عمليه سياسيه شامله
للجميع وتوسيع اليه المراقبه
مبادره وجدت دعما من الاتحاد الافريقي لكن
الخرطوم اعتبرتها مبادره احتلال جددت
رفضها رئاسه كينيا للجنه ايجاد الرباعيه
بسبب عدم حيادها وطالبت بان تبقى جنوب
السودان رئيسه لها على مسار اخر جاء توقيع
اعلان نوايا في مدينه جده في بدايه مايو
ضمن مبادره مشتركه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد
محادثات اوليه بين ممثل القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وممثل قوات الدعم السريع كان
ابرز ما حققته التوافق على هدن مؤقته
غالبا ما كانت هشه ووقف لاطلاق النار
نادرا ما التزم به الطرفان لمعالجه الوضع
الانساني لكنه ظل بعيدا عن الحديث عن حل
واضح يعالج عمق الازمه القائمه ويجد مخرجه
لها حتى الان
هذا ودع السفير النرويجي في السودان
اندروس يانسن المجتمع الدولي ودول الجوار
الى الاسراع في جهود الوساطه لوقف الحرب
في السودان وقال السفير النرويجي في نشره
سابقه للجزيره ان عمليه الوساطه الدوليه
والاقليميه تتسم بالبطء
على الاسره الدوليه ان ترص صفوفها يجب ان
نوضح للاطراف المتقاتله ان القتال ينبغي
ان يتوقف هم مسؤولون وسوف يسالون العقبات
الامريكيه موجوده ومن المؤكد ان الولايات
المتحده تنظر في جعلها اكثر تحديدا ولكن
ما يمكن للدول المجاوره ان تقوم به مهم
الايجاد الاتحاد الافريقي يمكنها ان تجد
سبيلا لزياده الضغط وربما اعاده تقييم
العمليه وما وصلت اليه حتى الان لانها
بطيئه اكثر من اللازم نحن بحاجه لما
يسرعها ويدفعها قدما
الا تجبوتي الرئيس الدوري لمنظمه الايجاد
ان موقفها من احترام سياده السودان وسلامه
ووحده اراضيه ثابت لا يتغير وابدا بيان
الرئاسه الجيبوتيه قلقه من استمرار
الاحداث في السودان وما ترتب عليها من ترد
الاوضاع الامنيه والانسانيه ودعا البيان
الى وقف فوريا للحرب وقبول اطراف الازمه
الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات لمعالجه اسباب
الازمه لتحقيق طموحات الشعب السوداني في
الحريه والعداله والديمقراطيه حسب تعبير
البيان
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك
ماذا يعني هذا التصريح للبرهان انه
يقبل يبدي قبولا للتعامل مع اي مبادره
تركيه
لحل الوضع في السودان رغم عدم وجود مبادره
عمليا نعم هذا هو الموقف الاول للجيش
السوداني بانه يقبل كل الوساطات التي تدعو
الى قفا الحرب كانت هنالك مبادرات من
مناطق مختلفه حتى اسرائيل قدمت مبادره
للحل فهو من الطبيعي يعني يستجيب لهذه
الدعاوي لا اعتقد ان هنالك ما يمنع
ازعاجات هذه المبادره من تركيا او من اي
جهه اخرى ولكن اعتقد ان التزاحم هذه
المبادرات المختلفه اذا كانت مبادرات تعبر
عن منظمات دوليه او تعبر عن منظمات
اقليميه او مبادرات لدول بشكل فردي اعتقد
ان هذا التسابق هو الذي يتيح مساحه اكبر
للاطراف للتهرب من كل التزامات كانت حول
دلاله بان ربما الجيش مستعد
لقبول التفاوض
وحسم الامور بعيدا عن الميدان لا هذه هي
الاشاره الاولى من اول يوم الجيش رحب بهذه
بكل الدعوات التي تدعو للتفاوض وايقاف
الحرب وقال انه الجيش ليس له في الحرب
اجنده خاصه هو يريد ان يبطل الاجنده
الخاصه بالدعم السريع الدعم السريع اراد
عبر هذه العمليه الانقلابيه ان يبتلع
الدوله السودانيه تقول عبر عمليه عسكريه
سياسيه تحدث تغييرات ديموغرافيه في
السودان لمصلحه اطراف اخرى حتى اسرار
اطراف عابره للحدود فالجيش ليس له اجنده
اكثر من ذلك فمنذ اليوم الاول اذا حدثت
استجابه من قبل الدعم السريع باي طريقه من
الطرق بان ينسحب من الاعيان المدنيه وان
يتنازل عن هذا المشروع
المشروع الذي يهدد وجود الدوله السودانيه
لاستجاب الجيش ولكن الا ترى ان لتصريح
البرهان بانه يقبل باي مبادره تركيه
دلاله خاصه خصوصا انه ياتي بعد حديثه
بالامس عن تسليح
واسع في السودان من اجل يعني وفهم على ان
يعني فهم من بعض الاطراف وكان هناك
استحاله من جانب الجيش الحسم
في الفحم لا اكثر اذا كان هذا الكرت ابداء
هذه الرغبه اذا جاءت في هذا التوقيت دون
ان يكون هنالك اثر سابق ودون ان تكون
هنالك دعوات سابقه ودون ان تكون هنالك
اقوال سابقه للبرهان ولقياده الجيش بانهم
على استعداد للتعامل مع كل المبادرات التي
تدعو لايقاف الحرب لكان ذلك التفسير صحيحا
ولكن هذا التفسير ياتي متسقا مع الموقف
الرسمي للجيش والموقف الرسمي للبرهان من
اول يوم الى هذه اللحظه
ايضا ما دلالات هذا الحديث بالنسبه لما
الات اليها الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه
الدعم السريع له مشكله مزدوجه هو انه يريد
ان يستغل هذه الهدى لترتيب اوضاعه
العسكريه وللتمدد باشكال مختلفه وكذلك
هنالك مجموعه كبيره من قوات الدعم السريع
باحتراف الدعم السريع اصبحت خارجيه خارجه
عن السيطره القياده المركزيه واصبحت ترتكب
كثير من التجاوزات المتعلقه باحتلال
المنازل والمتعلقه بعمليات السلبي والنب
الى درجه ان الدعم السريع شرع في تكوين
اللجنه حدد لها الشخص باسمه لان يتعامل مع
هذه التفلتات فهذا الوضع المعقد للدعم
السريع يجعل من الاستحاله الالتزام بكل
المشاريع التي تدعو لايقاف القتال او تدعو
لهدنه حتى ولو كانت هدنه تمتد الى ساعات
لان
مجموعات كبيره من الدعم الس ريع خارج هذه
السيطره وليست لها التزامات راسيه اتجاه
القياده
بتلبيه
والاستجابه لتوجيهاتها شكرا لك بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني معنا هنا
في استوديو الحصاد شكرا
في سياق اخر نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مصادر
عسكريه واستخباراتيه ان الافا من عناصر
الاستخبارات في عهد الرئيس السوداني
المعزول عمر البشير يقاتلون الى جانب
الجيش السوداني ضد قوات الدعم السريع
وذكرت الوكاله ان 6000 من عناصر
الاستخبارات ممن لهم صله بالحركه
الاسلاميه التي ينتمي اليها البشير انضموا
الى الجيش ويقاتلون معه قوات الدعم السريع
كما نقلت رويترز عن مصدر بالجيش السوداني
نفيه اي علاقه للجيش باي حزب سياسي او
ايديولوجي وتاكيده ان الجيش مؤسسه محترفه
ونقلت الوكاله عن مصدر بالجيش ومصدر
استخباراتي ان معظم اعضاء جهاز المخابرات
العامه الذي حل بعد اسقاط البشير انضموا
للجيش لكن بعض اعضائه انضموا للدعم السريع
ايضا
[موسيقى]
تشهد ضواحي مدن فرنسيه عديده توترا امنيا
لليله الثانيه على خلفيه مقتل شابا يبلغ
من العمر 17 عاما صباح الثلاثاء برصاص
شرطي في ضاحيه نونتير جنوب غربي باريس من
بين المناطق التي تشهد توترا ضاحيه نوتير
وضواحن باريسيه اخرى اضافه الى احياء
شعبيه في مدن تولوز واليوم وليل وقد اعلن
وزير الداخليه الفرنسي اعتقال 31 شخصا بعد
اعمال عنف وحرق طالت عددا من المقر
الامنيه في بعض ضواحي باريس وقال ان 24
شرطيا اصيب بينما دفعت الوزاره بالفين
شرطي للحفاظ على النظام العام ومددت
السلطات واعتقال الشرطي الذي اطلق الرصاص
على الشاب حيث يتم التحقيق معه بتهمه
القتل العمد ووعد المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الفرنسيه بتقديم اجابات لعائله الشاب
القتيل
وقال الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكرون انه
يشارك عائله ومحبي الشاب نائل حزنهم
ويتركوا للعداله اثبات الحقيقه اضاف
ماكرون في تغريده على تويتر ان افراد شرطه
الفرنسيه والدرك ملتزمون بحمايه الشعب
والجمهوريه وانهم يفعلون ذلك في اطار
اخلاقي يجب احترامه وعبر مكروه عن امله ان
تنتهي التحقيقات بسرعه
معنى من ضاحيه نونتير الغربيه باريس مراسل
الجزيره لطفي المسعودي لطفي نقترب اكثر
معك من المشهد وايضا ما المتوقع في
الساعات المقبله
الى حد هذه اللحظه تبدو الامور هادئه هنا
في ضحيه اوتار عاصمه الفرنسيه باريس طبعا
لتوالي دعوات التهدئه من اعلى هرم السلطه
هنا في باريس في فرنسا بدء الرئيسي الذي
دعا الى الهدوء والى ترك المجال للعداله
لتاخذ مجراها قائلا ان فرنسا كلها ترغب في
معرفه الحقيقه الكامله عن حادثه مقتل
الشاب هنا في ضحيه هذا بالاضافه الى
التعزيزات الامنيه الكبيره التي شهدناها
في هنا في اكثر من 2000 رجل تم تعبئته
لحفظ النظام هذا المساء وذلك اجتنابا
لتكرار ما حدث ليله امس ليله امس التي
شهدت حرب اكثر من 40
سياره وجرح اكثر من 24 رجل ام المعتقال
اكثر من 30 شخصا من الاشخاص القادرين
الذين كانوا يتظاهرون ضد الشرطه وعمدوا
الى حرق واجهات بعض المحلات وكذلك حرق
السيارات هنا في المنطقه ولكن بالنظر الى
التطورات الاخيره التي تشهدها مدينه تولوز
في جنوب البلاد والتي عمد فيها
وحاويات
القمامه وبعض السيارات في شوارع وذلك طبعا
الرد على نفس الحادثه التي جدت هنا في فان
رجال الامر هنا في غ
رب
متحفظون لاي حركه قد تستوجب تدخلهم وهم
منتشرون بكثافه تقريبا في جميع الانهوج في
شوارع مدينه نوطير غربه شكرا لك لطفي
المسعودي مراسلنا من ضحيه نونتير في غرب
باريس
[موسيقى]
تلاحقت الادانات عربيا واسلاميا لاقدام
شخص سويدي على احراق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف في تظاهرات وسط العاصمه السويديه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان احراق الكتب
الدينيه امر مؤذن ويظهر عدم الاحترام
وكانت الشرطه السويديه سمحت بتنظيم هذه
التظاهره خارج مسجد ستوكهولم الرئيسي
اليوم اول ايام عيد الاضحى وجاءت موافقه
شرطه السويديه بعد اسبوعين من رفض محكمه
استئناف حظرا كانت قد اعلنته الشرطه على
المظاهرات التي تنظم لاحراق المصحف الشريف
ياتي هذا بعدما ادى تحرك من هذا القبيل
خارج مقر سفاره التركيه في كانون الثاني
يناير الماضي الى خروج مظاهرات استمرت
اسابيع ورفقتها دعوات لمقاطعه المنتجات
السويديه
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره بمقتل خمسه فلسطينيين
داخل الخط الاخضر في جرائم ذات خلفيه
جنائيه شهدتها بلداتهم في اقل من 24 ساعه
هذه الحادثه وغيرها تعيد تسليط الضوء على
تفشي جرائم القتل الجنائي ضد فلسطيني داخل
وسط اتهامات للشرطه واجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه بشان تعاملها مع هذه الجرائم
ومرتكبيها
داخل الخط الاخضر يسيل كثير من الدماء
بجرائم قتل جنائيه يقتل خمسه من فلسطينيين
الداخل في بلدات مختلفه في غضون 24 ساعه
في الثامن من الشهر الجاري قتل ايضا خمسه
فلسطينيين دفعه واحده باطلاق الرصاص عليهم
في مغسله للسيارات في بلده يافتي الناصره
الان ومع انتصاف العام الحالي بلغت حصيله
جرائم القتل الجنائيه 111 هذا الرقم يحصي
جرائم قتل جنائيه ضد الفلسطينيين الداخل
نفذت من عصابات واشخاص يحوزون اسلحه ناريه
يحدث هذا كله واحيانا في وضح النهار داخل
مناطق الخط الاخضر اي الاراضي التي
احتلتها اسرائيل عام 48 ويفترض ان الشرطه
والاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه موجوده فيها
ولها اليد طوله ومسؤوله عن الحاله الامنيه
وانفاذ القانون وضبط السلاح
وغيرها من المهام لكن تلك الاجهزه نفسها
تواجه اتهاما بالتراخي استنادا الى تقرير
نشرته صحيفتها فان الشرطه الاسرائيليه حلت
اقل من خمسه في المئه فقط من ملابسات
جرائم القتل في المجتمعات الفلسطينيه في
الداخل مقارنه بحل اكثر من 83% من حالات
القتل في اسرائيل
اما القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه
فنقلت عن مصادر في الشرطه قولهم ان منفذي
الجرائم معظمهم من المتعاونين مع جهاز
المخابرات الداخليه المعروف بالشبك وان
ذلك يكمل يد الشرطه في التعامل معهم
من اين ياتي هذا السلاح لمرتكبي الجرائم
الجنائيه تقرير لصحيفتها قبل نحو عامين عن
عمليات السرقه من مستودعات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ثم تباع بالسوق السوداء اخر
هذه السرقات كانت قبل ايام من القاعده
العسكريه
في صحراء النقب
[موسيقى]
يخرج الفلسطينيون الخط الاخضر في مظاهرات
احتجاجا على ترد الحاله الامنيه في مدنهم
وبلداتهم وتفشي جرائم القتل فمن يكون
المستفيد الاول من حاله عدم الامان هذه
واستمرار حاله التهديد الجدي لحاله
الفلسطينيين داخل الخط الاخضر
[موسيقى]
قائمه العار هو عنوان تعارفت عليه وسائل
الاعلام لقائمه من الدول تضعها الامم
المتحده تركز بشكل اساسي على المتورطين في
تجديد واستغلال الاطفال والعنف الجنسي
ضدهم وقتلهم وتشويهم ولهجمات على المدارس
او المستشفيات والقائمه تطول الفكره بدات
عام 2022 من الامين العام للامم المتحده
حينها والهدف بحسب ما اعلن استخدام
القائمه كاداه لكبح الانتهاكات ضد الاطفال
خلال النزاعات المسلحه الشخص المخول
بادراج اي دوله على القائمه هو الامين
العام للامم المتحده وفي هذه الحاله
نتحدثون عن انطونيو بوتيريش غوتيريش خرج
بتقريره السنوي للعام 2022 وفيه ادرج في
القائمه لاول مره دوله دائمه العضويه في
الامم واحده وهنا نتحدث عن روسيا بسبب ما
يحدث في اوكرانيا القائمه من جديد استثنت
اسرائيل على الرغم من انها تاتي في
المرتبه الثانيه في التقرير نفسه من حيث
عدد الانتهاكات بعد بوركينا فاسو لنقف
قليلا عندما تعنيه المرتبه الثانيه ببعض
الارقام التي تناولها التقرير الاممي ذاته
رصد التقرير وقوع ثلاثه
الاف133 انتهاكا جسيما فالضفه الغربيه
المحتله بما فيها القدس الشرقيه وقطاع غزه
يشير التقرير ايضا الى استخدام القوات
الاسرائيليه اربعه اطفال فلسطينيين دروعا
بشريه ويرصد احتجاز اسرائيل اكثر من 800
طفل فلسطيني ويشير الى سوء معامله قوات
الاحتلال للاطفال الفلسطينيين المحتجزين
وكما رصد مقتل 54 طفلا فلسطينيا منهم 42
على يد قوات الامن الاسرائيليه
من باريس ينضم الينا
رئيس جمعيه عداله وحقوق بلا حدود سيد
فرانسوا دوروش لماذا باعتقادك استثنيت
اسرائيل من قائمه العار رغم ورودها في
المرتبه الثانيه من التقرير المتعلق
بالانتهاكات انتهاكات الدول ضد الاطفال
مساء الخير لكم جميعا نحن نتحدث عن
استثناء غريب لطالما كان كانت دوله
اسرائيل الطفل المدلل للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وللامم المتحده نحن نتحدث عن
وضع صعب في فلسطين وهناك سياسه الكيل
بمكيالين حيث اننا نتحدث عن اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف ممارسه في حق اكثر من الف طفل
فلسطيني ونتحدث عن ايضا ضرر لاحق باطفال
في الضفه الغربيه تعرضوا لقصف اسرائيلي
والتقرير بن الصادر عن الامم المتحده لا
يضيف اسرائيل على قائمه العار على عكس ما
فعلوا مع روسيا طبعا يجب ان تضاف روسيا
ولكن لا نفهم كيف
للامين العام للامم المتحده لا يضيف
اسرائيل الى هذه القائمه اعتقد ان مجموعه
الضغط
نعم تفضل تفضل تفضل هذا ما كنت اريد ان
اسالك عنه يعني باعتقادك ما التفسير لعدم
اضافتها الى هذه القائمه لماذا يقدم على
مثل هكذا خطوه الامين العام
لماذا يقدم على هذه الخطوه نحن نتحدث عن
سياسه الكيل بمكيالين وهي مستمره على
مستوى الامم المتحده اسرائيل هي الطفل
المدلل للدول الغربيه ولولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتتفلت من العقاب واليوم نتحدث
عن
3133 انتهاك بحق الاطفال
الفلسطينيين وفقد ثمانيه اطفال اسرائيليين
تعرضوا لصواريخ اطلقت من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه امام احد يفهم ذلك كل المنظمات
الدوليه لا تفهم ذلك منظمتنا خاطبت امين
العام للامم المتحده بحثا عن تفسير لان كل
التبريرات والشروحات في العالم لا يمكنها
ان تبرر هذا الاستثناء الاسرائيلي وهذا
الاستثناء
اسرائيل لا ياتي بالفائده للاطفال في
فلسطين وفي اسرائيل
هل تلقيتم اي رد سيد فرانسوا على
استفساركم هذا الذي قلت انكم كجمعيه
وجهتموه الى الامم المتحده
كلا لم نحصل على اي رد لاننا خاطبناهم منذ
ايام قليله وبالتالي يتعين على الاليه
الدوليه ان تتحرك ولكننا نخاطب العالم
ويسعدني ان اقول لكم ما سوف يكون رد
الامين المتحده الان بهذه الخطوه عدم ضم
اسرائيل الى قائمه العار باعتقادك سيد
فرانسوا ما الرساله التي ترسل لاسرائيل
وايضا للفلسطينيين واطفال فلسطين
الرساله بسيطه الرساله بسيطه لماذا الامين
العام للامم المتحده لا يولي اهميه لحياتي
الاطفال الفلسطينيين كما يولي اهتماما
للاطفال في اوكرانيا وهذه هي بالفعل سياسه
الكيل بمكيلين نحن ننتظر رد السيد غوتارش
وسوف نعلن على الرد ولكن هذا الامر لم
يفاجئنا لان اسرائيل لم تحترم ابدا اي
قرار للامم المتحده منذ العام 1948 وها هي
تستمر في نفس المنهج وفي نفس السياسه
والسجاده الحمراء تفرش دائما لاسرائيل
بالرغم من كل الانتهاكات التي ارتكبتها
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قررت ايضا ان لا تمول مراكز
بحثيه موجوده في الاراضي التابعه للضفه
الغربيه لربما تغير الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه رايها ونظرتها هذا امر مختلف
ولكن بالنسبه الى المنظمات الدوليه
ومنظمات حقوق الانسان نحن نراقب
رئيس جمعيه عداله وحقوق بلا حدود ضيفنا من
باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تحت ظل الحرب تختصر الطفوله امام سيل من
المعاناه معاناه يندرج تحتها الكثير من
الانتهاكات والحرمان ولاطفالي كل بلد
حصتهم ونسختهم الخاصه وكما تساءلت اليوم
منظمات حقوقيه كثيره عن الفرق بين طفل
واخر ومعاناه واخرى في ميزان الادانه
يتساءل اطفال كثيرون ببراءه وهم يعانون
الم الحرب عما ينقصهم ليلتفت العالم اليهم
اكثر لهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه حصاد
هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم وتصبحون على
عالم افضل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]